สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensive ไยห้องเรียนภาษาไทยค่ะค่ะ
แล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กครูชิเเนี่ยมา
พบกันนะในวันอะไรคะครูชิวันอันนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะอังคารวันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่
คะ 13 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะอ่าปี
พ.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
2567 ค่ะอ่าปีค.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
2,000  24 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูชิ
เ่ะมาพบกับนักเรียนนะคะในวันนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่ 13 เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2500  67 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะ
อื้อหือวันนี้เนี่ยเรามาเจอกันในใน
เอ่อชั่วโมงเกี่ยวกับเกี่ยวกับธุรกิจดี
มั้ย
อื
อ๋อเราต้องบอกว่าเนาะมันมันเหมือนกับว่า
เวลาเราทำอะไรเราต้องรีบๆอ่ะเหมือนช่วง
เวลาที่ดีที่ควรทำอย่างงี้ใช่มั้ยธุรกิจ
อืนะอุ้ยตรงกับสำนวนไทยค่ะเรามี
สำนวนสำนวนเหมือนๆกับเป็นการเปรียบเทียบ
ใช่มั้ยใช่คนไทยจะมีการเปรียบเทียบถ้าพูด
ถึงเรื่องเนี้ยเปรียบเทียบกับอะไร
อ่าใช่ค่ะเรามีสำนวนว่าน้ำขึ้นให้รีบตัก
อ่าตักเร็วๆจะได้เยอะๆใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าใน
สมัยก่อนเนาะูชิบ้านเราเนี่ยมันก็ยังไม่
มีน้ำประปาใช่มั้ยอ่านะน้ำประปาเนี่ยก็
คือน้ำที่ตามบ้านที่เราใช้เนาอืนะเวลาเรา
เข้าห้องน้ำเราเข้าห้องครัวเราเปิดก๊อก
น้ำออกมามันก็จะมีน้ำไหลแล้วตอนนี้เนี่ย
สบายๆนะก็ไม่ต้องไปตักน้ำแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยว
เนี้ยอื้อหือนะน้ำเนี่ยมาถึงที่แต่เมื่อ
ก่อนนะเมื่อก่อนนะคะ 50  60 ปีที่แล้ว
เนี่ยยังต้องไปแล้วก็ไปตักนะบางคนเนี่ย
ต้องมีแบบโยกเอาน้ำจากใต้ดินไงเอาน้ำที่
อยู่ใต้ดินเนี่ยเอาขึ้นมาใช้เเพราะว่าใน
สมัยก่อนเนี่ยเราอ่ะต้องรอใช่มั้ยถ้ารอ
น้ำฝนอย่างเดียวเนี่ยนะเราก็ต้องต้องมี
อะไรที่สำหรับเก็บน้ำไว้เยอะๆเยอะๆมากๆพอ
ฝนตกลงมาก็เอาน้ำฝนเนี่ยเก็บเอาไว้
แต่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยปฝนตกเนี่ย 4 เดือนอื
ไม่ตกเนี่ย 8 เดือน
โอ้อันนี้ภาคกยอืใช่มยเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
เราต้องเก็บน้ำไว้อีกใช้อีก 8 เดือนเนี่ย
โอ้โหโอต้องเอาอะไรเก็บคะบ้านเรามีสัก 10
คนเอาตุ่มหรือโอ่งก็ได้ค่ะ
อืนะตุ่มก็จะเล็กไปเนาะูชิเนาะเเต้องโอ่ง
เลยนะใช่ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่านะตุ่มอ่ะก็จะเล็ก
ตุ่มแบบนี้นะอืตุ่มอ่าแต่บางทีเนี่ยเรา
เคยไปเสิร์ช Google มันจะออกมาเป็นตุ่ม
เหมือนกันค่ะอันนี้ก็
ตุ่มเป็นตุ่มอ่ะผิวเราเนี่ยเป็นตุ่มอัน
นี้ไม่ใช่นะอันนี้คนละตุ่มอันนี้เอ่อตุ่ม
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยต้องมีลายมังกรไใช่ค่ะ
จังหวัด
ราชบุรีอ่าเราเรียกตุ่มมังกรหรือโ่งมังกร
ใช่มยตุ่มก็จะเล็กๆหน่อยแต่ถ้าโอ่งเนี่ย
ก็จะใหญ่หน่อยนะเพราะว่าถ้าบ้านเราเนี่ย
โอ้โหเห็นมยมีคนหลายคนเราก็จะต้องต้องมี
โอ่งเก็บน้ำเนี่ยไว้ใช้เนี่ยนะโอ้โหกี่
โอ่งคะครูปุ๊กคะแล้วโอ่งกับตุ่มเนี่ยเชฟ
ไม่เหมือนกันค่ะไม่เหมือนยังไงคะครูชิถ้า
บอกว่าเป็นตุ่มเนี่ยมันจะมันจะป่องตรง
กลางค่ะอืตรงกลางเนี่ยจะ
ป่องนะคะแต่ถ้าเป็นโอ่งเนี่ยมันมันมันมัน
อ้วนที่ข้างบนแล้วก็ลงลงมาข้างล่างอ้วน
ข้างบนลงมาข้างล่างเห็นมอือันนี้โข้างบ
ใช่ก็จะเก็บน้ำเยอะๆเนาะสำหรับแบบเก็บไว้
ใช้ค่ะนะส่วนมากน้ำกินเราก็จะใส่เป็นโอ่ง
มังกรหรือตุ่มมังกรเพราะว่ามันจะดูสวยงาม
อันนี้ก็แยกเป็นน้ำกินนะแล้วก็น้ำใช้ก็
ใช้อาบน้ำใช้ล้างจานนะ
อันนี้เป็นน้ำน้ำใช้ในสมัยก่อนเนี่ยบ้าน
คนไทยเนี่ยอยู่ติดกับแม่น้ำใช่มยเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราต้องใช้น้ำใช่ในการอาบใน
การซักเสื้อผ้านะในการทำอาหารก็ต้องอยู่
ใกล้ๆน้ำค่ะนะในการเดินทางด้วยก็ต้องอยู่
ใกล้ๆน้ำนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเวลาโอ่งเนี่ย
เก็บน้ำไม่พอพอหรอกเนอเราก็จะต้องแบบ
เหมือนบางทีเนี่ยเราต้องตักน้ำอันนี้คือ
ตุ่มอ่าตุ่มไม่
อ่าตุ่มเนี่ยไม่พอเก็บน้ำเหรอคะโอ่งก็ไม่
พอค่ะูชิเพราะว่าบอกแล้วว่า 8 เดือนเนี่ย
แล้วบ้านคนไทยอยู่กันหลายคนนะถ้ามีหลาย
โอ่งอย่างงี้ก็ยังไม่พออีกอันนี้คือตุ่ม
แล้วก็มีโอ่งมังกรอยู่เออันนี้คือโอ่งค่ะ
แล้วอันนี้
ตุ่มนะโป่ง
มังกรนะ
อ่านะก็แล้วแต่เนาะก็อันนี้ก็คืออันนี้
อ่าใหญ่ๆอย่างเงี้ยเราเรียกว่าโอ่งเก็บ
น้ำเราเก็บไว้ใช้ได้นานๆนะแต่ว่าทีนี้
เนี่ยบางทีมันไม่พอเราก็ต้องไปตักน้ำใน
แม่น้ำใช่มย
อหนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเวลาเค้าก็บอกว่าถ้า
น้ำขึ้นเนี่ยให้รีบตักอืเพราะว่าน้ำเนี่ย
จะใกล้กับสะพานเนาะ
อืเราก็จะรีบตักขึ้นมาเพื่อเอาไปเก็บมัน
ก็จะได้น้ำที่ไม่ขุ่นนะน้ำที่ใสกว่านะ
แล้วก็น้ำที่เยอะแล้วไม่ต้องก้มลงไปลึก
เนาะใช่
อืการเก็บแบบนี้ก็ง่ายสะดวกเร็วกว่าใช่มย
แต่ถ้ารอรอไปน้ำมันก็จะลงค่ะเพราะว่าน้ำ
เนี่ยถึงจะเป็นแม่น้ำบางทีมันก็จะมีน้ำ
ช่วงที่น้ำเยอะน้ำน้อยใช่มยน้ำขึ้นน้ำลง
นะแบบทะเลก็จะมีน้ำขึ้นน้ำลงทุกวันใช่มย
นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยนะเขาก็เลยบอกว่าสำนวน
ไทยเนาะก็จะเตือนให้คนน่ะรู้ว่าถ้าน้ำ
ขึ้นเมื่อไหร่ก็ต้องรีบตักเพราะว่าเรา
เนี่ยจะได้ประโยชน์มากนะก็เหมือนถ้าเอาไป
เปรียบเทียบในธุรกิจที่ครูชิจะบอกก็คือ
ว่านะเหมือนกับช่วงไหนที่มันเป็นช่วงที่
นะเป็นธุรกิจที่แบบเหมือนบูมขึ้นมาคนนิยม
อะไรแล้วอยากได้อยากใช้อะไรเนี่ยแล้วลทำ
ให้เร็วที่สุดนะเพื่อที่จะให้ทุกคนเนี่ย
นะเค้าเพราะว่าทุกคนอยากได้อ่ะความ
ต้องการมันสูงไงความต้องการอยากได้เยอะนะ
ซื้อเท่าไหร่ก็ได้เราต้องผลิตให้ทันมีให้
พออือนะอ่ะคิดง่ายๆเลยเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยนะใน
สมัยก่อนเนี่ยจริงๆอ่ะอย่างครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ไม่ชอบเสื้อสีเหลืองค่ะอือหือ
อ้าวทำไมคะทำไมครูปุ๊กไม่ชอบเสื้อสี
เหลืองไม่รู้อ่ะเสื้อคุกเนี่ยถ้าซื้อ
เนี่ยไม่มีสีเหลืองเลยครูชิถ้าเปิดตู้มา
เนี่ยจะเห็นสีดำ
เยอะสีขาวพอประมาณแล้วก็มีสีอื่นๆยังไม่
เยอะเท่าไหร่เนาะนะแต่ว่าสีเหลืองเนี่ย
ไม่มี
ค่ะเพราะว่าไม่ชอบสีเหลืองอืหรือว่าใส่สี
เหลืองแล้วไม่สวยใส่สีเหลืองเนี่ยทุกคนก็
บอกว่าว่าสวยนะแต่ครููบุ๊กก็ไม่ชอบสี
เหลืองเองไม่ชอบเองอ่ะรู้สึกว่าเราอ่ะไม่
ชอบสีเหลืองเพราะว่าเรารู้สึกว่าสีเหลือง
เนี่ยมันไม่สวยอืนะเราก็ไม่ซื้อมาใส่ใช่
มยนะแต่ว่าช่วงนึงอ่ะที่คนไทยเนี่ยใส่
เสื้อสีเหลืองกันแบบโอ้โหแทบจะทุกคนน่ะ
ครูุคิดว่า 90 กว่าเปอร์เซ็นน่ะที่ใส่
เสื้อเหลืองนะถ้าย้อนกลับไปนะครูชิ
โยนกลับไปเนี่ยนะตอนสมัยในหลวงภูมิพลใช่
มั้ยในหลวงที่ 9 ที่ 9 ใช่ของกรุง
รัตนโกสินทร์หรือกรุงเทพเนี่ยนะในหลวง
รัชกาลที่ 9 เพราะว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยรัชกาล
ที่ 10 ใช่มั้ยเป็นลูกนะแต่เมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยตอนปี
2549 เนาะอื 2  5  4  9 เนาะก็ตอนนั้น
เนี่ยในหลวงในหลวงภูมิพลเนี่ยเป็นในหลวง
ครบ 60 ปี
อื้อหือนะอันเนี้ยเป็นเป็นในหลวงมานาน 60
ปีแล้วใช่ค่ะนะเป็นในหลวงนะไม่ใช่อายุนะ
นะก็เป็นในหลวงมาครบ 60 ปีเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยตอนนั้นเนี่ยคนไทยเนี่ยเหมือนเราก็
จัดงานแบบยิ่งใหญ่มากนะสำหรับให้ในหลวงนะ
เพราะว่าอย่างคนจีนเขาก็นิยมแบบแซยิกหรือ
อะไรอย่างเงี้ย 60 ปีอย่างเงี้ยค่ะ 60
เหมือนโชคดีไงโชคดีชอ่านะ
แล้ววันที่เราจะใส่ก็คือเป็นวันเ้าบอกว่า
ใส่ตั้งแต่วันที่ 1 ถึงวันที่ 9 ค่ะ 9
วันอื้อหือนะก็ใครอยากคือไม่ได้บังคับเน
ไม่ใช่ว่าทุกคนต้องใส่สีเหลืองนะใครอยาก
ใส่ก็ใส่ใครไม่มีไม่ใส่ก็ไม่ได้ว่าอะไรนะ
คือตอนนั้นเหมือนๆกับเชิญชวนชวนเอ้ยเรามา
ใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองให้กับในหลวงที่ 9 เพราะ
ในหลวงที่ 9 เนี่ยเกิดวันจันทร์นะคะสีวัน
จันทร์ก็คือสีเหลืองใช่มั้ยในหลวงก็จะมี
ธงใช่มั้ยเวลาในหลวงเนี่ยข้างล่างอ่ะปุ๊บ
มันจะมีธงใช่มั้ยธงของในหลวงก็จะเป็นสี
เหลืองเหมือนกันอ่าเนี่ยตั้งโลโก้เห็น
มั้ยคะโลโก้ในหลวงเนี่ยจะมีธงเป็นสี
เหลืองเพราะว่าเป็นวันเกิดของในหลวงวัน
จันทร์อ่าใชค่ะนะเค้าก็เลยเอ่อเราก็เลย
คุยกันเนาว่าเอ่อก็อยากจะเฉลิมฉลองในหลวง
เราครบ 60 ปีเป็นในหลวงที่เป็นในหลวงนาน
ที่สุดในตอนนั้นใช่มั้ยก็เลยอยากจะเฉลิม
ฉลองให้แบบเยอะมากๆอะไรอย่างเงี้ยทุกคนก็
อยากจะใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองค่ะนะเรามาใส่
เสื้อสีเหลืองกันดีกว่าให้กับในหลวงอืใช่
ค่ะแล้วตอนนั้นเนี่ยเสื้อสีเหลืองเนี่ยก็
จะต้องมีเหมือนเค้าก็จะมีตราสัญลักษณ์
เนาะอืออันเนี้ยเใครจะเอามาปักไม่ได้นะ
ต้องไปขออนุญาตก่อนนะฮต้องไปขออนุญาตในใน
วังนะคะที่วังจะมีเจ้าหน้าที่ใช่มั้ยใคร
จะเอาเอ่อโลโกของในหลวงเนี่ยไปติดที่ไหน
ที่ไหนอะไรอย่างเงี้ยต้องมีการขออนุญาตอ
เอาโลโก้ไปทำธงติดที่บ้านเอาโลโก้ไปทำ
เสื้อนะให้ในหลวงอย่างงี้อืใช่ค่ะแล้ว
เรียกว่าตราสัญลักษณ์เนาะอืนะซึ่งเขาคก็
จะออกแบบมาแต่ว่าตรงกลางเนี่ยก็จะเป็นตรา
สัญลักษณ์ประจำพระองค์ก็คือในหลวงรัชกาล
ที่ 9 ภูมิพลใช่มั้ยนะแล้วแล้วก็จะออกแบบ
ในแต่ละปีที่มันต่างกันนะก็อันเนี้ย
โอ้โหตอนแรกเนี่ยครูปุ๊กคือเราจะต้องใส่
เนี่ยนะเฉลิมฉลองในเดือนมิถุนายนก็คือ
เดือนที่ 6 อนะแต่เสื้อเนี่ยเริ่มมีวาง
ขายตั้งแต่เดือนพฤษภาคมเดือนที่ 5 และอื
ก็มีวางขายเนี่ยแต่ผ้าเนื้อไม่ค่อยดีเท่า
ไหร่นะอือเนื้อผ้าเนี่ยไม่ค่อยดีเท่าไหร่
ตัวนึงน่ะตอนนั้นครูบุ๊กไปดูเนี่ยนะผ่าน
แล้วก็เห็นก็เอ้อตัวเท่าไหร่คะแม่ค้าก็
บอกว่า
280 อื้อหืออ่า 280 แต่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยรู้
สึกว่าผ้าเนื้อไม่ค่อยดีแล้วก็
อืสีเนี่ยไม่สวยสีมันแบบเหลืองลืใช่มั้
มันจะเหลืเหลืองมากมันจะเหลืองแบบลักษณะ
เหลืองแบบเนี้ย
ค่ะมันไม่ได้เหลืองแบบเหลืองแบบนี้นะอ๋อ
ครูปุ๊กชอบเหลืองแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยก็ใส่ได้
ค่ะแต่รู้สึกว่าเหลืองแบบนี้เนี่ยอมันยัง
ไม่สวยแต่ว่านะก็เลยคิดว่าไม่เป็นไรหรอก
รอไปก่อนก็ได้อือหือ 280 โอเคก็ที่บ้าน
ครูปุ๊กถ้าซื้อเนี่ยก็ 4 คนใช่มยครูปุ๊ก
สามีลูก 2 คน 4 คนออ่ะอย่างน้อยที่สุด
ต้องมีคนละ 2 ตัวอืนะแล้วก็ไม่รู้ว่าคุณ
พ่อคุณแม่เนี่ยมีหรือเปล่าอือนะแต่ว่าก็
คิดไว้ก่อนแหละว่าซื้อ 4 ตัวอืเอ่อ 8 ตัว
เพราะว่าคนละ 2 ตัวคนละ 2  2  2  4 คนก็ 8
ตัวอืใช่ก็ก็คิดว่าอืยังยังไม่ถึงเวลานะ
มันน่าจะมีอีกเยอะอ่ะอืนะก็ผ่านไปค่ะเวลา
ก็ผ่านไปนะเดือนที่ 5 เนี่ยพอประมาณซัก
วันที่
20  21  22 ก็เริ่มมีมาขายแต่ไปดูเนี่ย
ูชิ
อือหือ
นะพอใกล้ๆปลายเดือนเนี่ยราคามันแพงขึ้น
ค่ะจาก 280 เนี่ยเป็น 300
ตอนเนี้ยมัน 300 บาทแล้วใช่นะเดือน
มิถุนายนใช่มั้ยยังไม่ถึงค่ะแค่กลางแค่
ปลายเดือนประมาณซักวันที่
25 พฤษภาคม 5
พฤษภาคมใช่นะก็ราคาเนี่ยมันก็ขึ้นไป 300
อันนี้เนี่ยตอนที่ต้นๆเดือนใช่มั้ยใช่นะ
แต่ว่าครูบุ๊กก็
เออซื้อมานะแต่ซื้อมาเนี่ยแค่ตอนนั้น
เนี่ยซื้อมาแค่ 2 ตัวของครูปุ๊กกับสามี
ใช่มยของลูกเนี่ยเขาตัวเล็กก็ยังยังไม่
ได้ดูให้นะก็เลยซื้อมาตัวละ 300 ก็โอเคก็
แต่
พอวันที่ 28 นะไปก็เห็นราคาเนี่ย 350
แล้วค่ะโขึ้นเร็วมาก 28 นะคะวันที่
28  28 พฤษภาคมใช่มั้ยใช่
นะจากราคา 300 เขึ้นไป
350  50
บาทโอ้โหโหครูบุ๊กก็เลยซื้อมานะ 4 ตัวนะ
แล้วก็ยังต้องมีของลูกอีก 2 ตัวเนาะก็
เดี๋ยวก็รอดูว่าเผื่อจะมีสวยๆนะเพราะไม่
อยากได้แค่เสื้อโปโลธรรมดานะอยากให้มันดู
แบบแบบมีอะไรที่มันแปลกๆบ้างนิดนึงออ่าก็
รอค่ะพอวันที่ 30 นะ
โอ้ราคา
ทำไมราคาเนี่ยมันขึ้นตลอด
โอ้โหใช่เพราะว่าคนไทยใส่กันเยอะมากไงคุณ
ชิแล้วทุกคนก็อยากได้ตราสัญลักษณ์นะที่
เป็นตราสัญลักษณ์แบบนี้ที่กระเป๋าเสื้ออื
ใช่มยอ่าแล้วดูคนไทยใส่อย่างเงี้ยครูชิดู
ซิ 90 กว่าเปอร์เซ็นของคนไทยอ่ะใส่อ่ะนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยของทำไม่ทันค่ะครูุไปอีก
ครั้งนึงครูบุ๊กก็ถามคำว่าเอ่อของมีมั้ย
คะเบอกว่าไม่มีพี่เดี๋ยวเย็นเนี้ยหนูต้อง
ไป
รอไปรอเอาของไม่บางทีได้มาแค่ 10 ตัว 20
ตัวได้มานิดหน่อยเท่านั้นก็เลยแบบูก็โอเค
ก็อย่างงั้นเดี๋ยวมาดูใหม่อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อื้อหือปรากฏว่าตอนเช้าวันที่ 31 ราคา 400
บาทแล้วค่ะ 1 วันขึ้นไปเลย
อื 400 บาทแล้วใช่แล้วก็ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยจะ
ซื้อให้คุณพ่อด้วยนะอือแต่อันนี้ผ้าดีค่ะ
เป็นผ้านาโนตอนนั้นอืนะครูุ๊ก็โอเคไม่
เป็นไรเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวมาค่ะเดี๋ยวมาตอนเย็น
ใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าไม่อยากถือซื้อไปแล้วถือ
ไปที่ทำงานตอนเย็นจะต้องผ่านอยู่แล้วก็
ไม่ต้องถือจากที่ทำงานกลับบ้านใช่มยอนะ
อ้ากุณปุ๊ไม่กลัวมันขึ้นราคาเหรอคะเอ้าก็
วันไปออฟฟิศกลับมาต่อไปอันนี้มัน 1 วัน 20
บาทใช่มยเช้าไปเนี่ยเย็นกลับมันน่าจะยัง
ไม่ขึ้นไงครูชิค่ะแต่ครูุคิดผิดจริง
ๆตอนกลับมาเนี่ยครูุกถามเนี่ยมีเสื้อห้อย
อยู่แบบตัวใหญ่ใช่มยเออก็คิดซื้อให้คุณ
พ่อถามราคาเท่าไหร่เพราะเมื่อเช้าถามแล้ว
นะ
400  500 ค่ะโอ้เห็นมั้ยครูปุ๊กอันเนี้ย
เนี่ยวันเดียวกัน
31 เช้ากับเย็นแต่อันเนี้ยตอนเย็นอันนี้
ตอนตอนกลางวันตอนเช้าใช่มั้ยใช่เช้าเนี่ย
400 บาทตอนเย็นเนี่ย 500 โอ้โหทำไมมัน
ขึ้นเร็วจังอ่ะเพราะว่าไม่มีเสื้อขายค่ะ
เพราะว่าทุกคนน่ะอยากจะใส่ให้กับในหลวง
ใช่มยนะแล้วก็ทุกคนก็จะซื้อแล้วใส่ 9 วัน
น่ะูชิคงไม่มีใครซื้อตัวนึงแล้วก็ใส่ทุก
วันไม่ซัก 9 วันน่ะเพราะประเทศไทยก็มัน
แพงไงก็ซื้อตัวเดียวใส่ทุกวัน
เลยก็เลยแบบแหมนะเราก็คิดว่าเออพระองค์
ท่านทำอะไรให้คนไทยเยอะเราทำแค่นี้เรา
ซื้อใส่เพื่อท่านวันนึง 2 วันแบบ 9 วัน
เนี่ยไม่เห็นเป็นไรเลยอะไรอย่างเงี้ยอือ
นะครูบุ๊กก็เลยไปหาซื้อพยายามหาซื้อนะ
หลายๆยี่ห้อ
โอ้โหแพงทุก 450 บ้างนะตัวเล็กๆนะ
450  500  550  600  800 ก็มีค่ะนะตอน
นั้นเนี่ยมีตั้งแต่ราคา
450 จนถึง
800 ใช่ค่ะ
นะแพงมาก 800 เนี่ยผ้าจะดีผ้าเป็นนาโนสวย
เย็บดีใช่มั้ยแต่ถ้าแบบผ้าแบบเหมือนผ้า
โหลอ่ะยังขาย 400  450 อย่างเงี้ยโอ้โหโห
กำไรอย่างเยอะนะคะไม่เ
คือเขาอาจจะรับมาหลายต่อไงโรงงานเนี่ยทำ
ไม่ทันน่ะคนเย็บเย็บไม่ทันค่ะเพราะว่ามี
แม่ค้าพ่อค้าเนี่ยไปรอทั้งวันทั้งคืนน่ะ
ูชิเขาบอกเขาไปรอกันทั้งวันทั้งคืนเพื่อ
จะเอาของมาขายกูกุ๊กจริงๆเนี่ยเย็บเนี่ย
ใช้เวลาไม่นานอืแต่ที่นานเนี่ยคือปักปัก
ปักโลโก้ที่กระเป๋าอ่ะค่ะเออรอโลโก้โ
กระเป๋าอันเนี้ยปักนานวันนึงเนี่ยอาจจะ
ปักได้ไม่กี่ไม่กี่แผ่นนะคะมันที่กระเป๋า
อ่ะค่ะแล้วก็เป็นต้องปักมันต้องใช้จาก
คอมพิวเตอร์ไงตึกๆๆๆๆๆๆกว่าจะได้ 1 ตัวนะ
อาจจะใช้เวลา 20 นาทีได้ 1 ตัว 20 นาที 1
ตัวมันก็จะมันช้าตรงลายปักเนี่ยมันไม่มี
นะเพราะว่าต้องมาติดกระเป๋าเนาะนั่นแหละ
ตอนนั้นเนี่ยโอ้โหเาบอกน้ำขึ้นให้รีบตัก
เนี่ยแม่ค้าพ่อค้าเนี่ยโอ้โหทำกันแบบไม่
หวาดไม่ไหวอ่ะคนเย็บครูุ๊คิดว่าแทบจะไม่
ได้นอนน่ะนักเรียนทั้งวันทั้งคืนจริงๆ
เพราะว่าเขาบอกแม่ค้าเนี่ยหลายๆคนนะบอกไป
รอคิวเพื่อไปเอาของเนี่ยโรงงานไม่มีให้
อ่ะคือบางทีต้องรอแบบเหมือนนอนแล้วก็รอ
เอาอ่ะอนะก็ยังขายได้วันที่ 1  2  3  4  5
6  7  8 ก็ยังขายได้ค่ะนะถึงวันที่ 9 ก็
ยังขายได้เพราะว่านะหลังจากนั้นมาเนี่ย
เราก็ใส่กันทุกวันจันทร์เนาะอื
นะซื้อซื้อแล้วก็ยังเฉลิมฉลองให้ทุกทุก
วันเกิดของในหลวงที่ 9 นะใช่ค่ะเราก็
พร้อมใจกันใส่ถ้านักเรียนมาตอนช่วงนะปี
ก่อนๆนู้นนะตั้งแต่ปี 50 เนี่ยเป็นต้นมา
ก็เราก็ก็ยังใส่วันจันทร์ทุกวันจันทร์
เสื้อสีเหลืองก็มีหลายๆคนเนี่ยที่สงสัยไง
ว่าทำไมคนไทยใส่เสื้อเหลืองกันเยอะจังแต่
เพราะว่าวันอังคารเอ้าไม่ใช่สีเหลือง
แล้วอันเนี้ยทำให้ธุรกิจของเอ่อบางคน
เนี่ยรวยมากนะเพื่อนูชิเนี่ยทำงานเปิด
เป็นโรงงานเย็บเสื้อนะคะผ้าตัดแล้วค่ะมี
ลงปักเครื่องคอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ยปักทีงเนี่ย
มีมีหัวเข็มเนี่ย 12 นะคะแต่วันนึงเนี่ย
มันได้ไม่กี่ไม่ไม่กี่10บตัวไม่ถึง 100
ตัวประมาณ 20 แผ่น 50 แผ่นเร่งทั้งวัน
ทั้งคืนนะ
นะนะก็ยังทำได้น้อยเลยใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าตง
กระเ๋าอ่าใช่นะคือถ้าเกิดปักได้เยอะนะ
แป๊บเดียวติดกับคือง่ายๆคือตัวเสื้อเนี่ย
เย็บเสร็จหมดแล้วรอกระเป๋ามาติดแล้วก็ขาย
ที่ช้านี่ก็คือกระเป๋าที่มีโลโก้นี่แหละ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ตอนนั้นนี่เป็นแบบอะไรที่
โอ้โหคนไทยเนี่ยแบบเราจะเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
กระตือรือล้นเหรอเราแบบอยากทำอยากทำอยาก
ใส่ให้กับในหลวงอย่างเงี้ยเนาะเราอยากไป
แบบโอ้โหนะคนไทยเราพูดมั้ยฟีเวอร์มันก็
เหมือนกันนะแบบมันกำลังแบบเป็นที่แบบทุก
อย่างเนี่ยแบบจะต้องแบบทำเหมือนๆกันพร้อม
ๆกันเยอะๆอืนะคะก็เลยเราก็อืนะเกิดภาพนี้
ขึ้นมาเนี่ยว่าอันนี้เฉพาะแค่หน้าพระที่ิ
นั่งเท่านั้นนะแต่ว่าคนไทยจริงๆแล้วทั่ว
ประเทศค่ะที่ใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองนะแล้วภาพ
มันเก็บไม่หมดนะถนนราชดำเนินน่ะค่ะค่ะยา
มากนักเรียนนะคะแล้วทุกคนใส่เสื้อสี
เหลืองสีเหลืองสีเหลืองสีเหลืองนะคะใส่
กันเยอะจนเอ่อเรารู้สึกว่าอยากจะใส่ด้วย
เลยอืออยากจะใส่ไปร่วมเอ่อเฉลิมฉลองนะคะ
ใส่ไปแสดงความยินดีใส่ไปขอบคุณในหลวงนะคะ
ในตอนนั้นนี่ค่ะพระที่นั่งอนันตสมาคม
อือหือแล้วในหลวงก็อยู่ที่พระที่นั่งนะ
ประชาชนก็โอ้โหยถนนราชดำเนินยาวเลยแค่บก
มือแต่ไม่เห็นท่านก็ไม่เป็นไรแต่ว่าคนก็
ยังอยาก
ไปูไม่ได้ไปที่นั่นเพราะว่าคนเยอะมากแต่
ว่าก็ยังใส่เนาะทุกคนก็ใส่ถึงแต่ตอนกลาง
คืนเราก็มีแบบร้องเพลงให้กับในหลวงงนะนะ
ใช่อื
นะตอนนั้นก็เลยกลายเป็นแบบ
โอ้โหเขาบอกน้ำขึ้นต้องรีบตักค่ะให้รีบ
ตักก็คือโอ้โหเสื้อเหลืองเนี่ยไม่ว่าจะ
เป็นอะไรก็ทำเป็นสีเหลืองหมดเลยนะไม่ว่า
ยี่ห้ออะไรก็ทำเป็นสีเหลืองออกมาไม่มี
โลโก้ก็มีคนใส่เพราะว่าอยากได้เสื้อสี
เหลืองเนาะแล้วก็ทุกคนก็ใส่ตอนนั้นโอ้โห
นะก็เลยเป็นช่วงที่แบบคนที่ทำธุรกิจเสื้อ
สีเหลืองเนี่ยร่ำรวยกันเป็นแถวๆใช่ค่ะ
เพื่อนเพื่อนูชิก็อีกคนนึงเ้ามีทั้งโรง
งานปักแล้วก็โรงงานเย็บนะคะแล้วก็ทำเสื้อ
ขายนะคะแล้วเป็นคนขออนุญาตด้วยอไปทำ
เรื่องขอในพระราชวังอต้องมีเส้นนิดหน่อย
นะต้องรู้จักกับคนในพระราชวังนะแล้วก็ทำ
เรื่องทำเป็นหนังสือนะนักเรียนไม่ใช่ขอ
ง่ายๆนะทำหนังสือแล้วก็ก็ขออนุญาตใช้
โลโก้มาทำเสื้อนะขาย
อเราเรียกว่าตราสัญลักษณ์เนาะอืนะตรา
สัญลักษณ์ของพระองค์ช่วงช่วงครองราชย์
หรือว่าเป็นในหลวง 5 เอ่อ 60 ปีใช่ค่ะ
แล้วก็อีกครั้งนึงเนี่ยที่ครูปุ๊กเห็น
เนี่ยที่แบบ
โอ้โหอะไรอธุรกิจนี้มันจะอะไรจะขนาดนั้น
คือขายดิบขายดีใช่มั้ยใช่ขายดิบขายดีจน
แบบว่าต้องผลิตออกมาค่ะไม่พอขายค่ะครููชิ
อนะเพราะว่าช่วงก่อนโควิดอ่ะูชิจำได้มั้ย
ช่วงก่อนโควิดเนาะก่อนโควิดจะระบาดเนี่ย
ก็คือฝุ่นค่ะ PM  2.5 มาแล้วนะมันจะมี
ฝุ่นในอากาศเนี่ยเล็กๆเล็กๆเนี่ยนะแล้ว
กรุงเทพฯเยอะมากคนก็อาจจะ
แบบไอกันแบบนะก็เลยมีคนที่ไปซื้อหน้ากาก
n95
ค่ะโอ้โหไปซื้อกันเยอะมากอ่ะครูชิแล้วตอน
นั้นเนี่ยเป็นแล้วไม่ซื้อไม่ซื้อน้อยๆนะ
เ้าเรียกว่าซื้อแบบตุนน่ะกักตุนก็คือซื้อ
กลัวไม่มีไงกลัวหมดโอ้โหเเรียกว่ากวาด
กวาดหมดนี่ค่ะนะหน้ากาก n9 หน้าแพงค่ะอ
ครูปุ๊กก็ไปซื้อเหมือนกันค่ะเพราะว่าเรา
ก็เดินทางนะตอนนั้นเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่บ้าน
เราก็ต้องซื้อแล้วก็ต้องซื้อให้มากที่สุด
ที่เราซื้อได้อ่ะเพราะว่ามันไม่ใช่ใส่ 1
1 เดือน 1 อันใช่มยอื 1 อันเนี่ยก็ดูว่า
เราอ่ะอยู่ข้างนอกนานเท่าไหร่อนะเราใช้
นานเท่าไหร่แต่ถ้าทั้งวันเนี่ยก็ต้อง
เปลี่ยนใช่มยใช่ก็หมดไปะใช่นะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยก็ต้องซื้อค่ะเพราะเราก็ไม่อยากไป
หายใจเอาอากาศอื้อหือที่ไม่ดีใช่มยมีฝุ่น
ละอองเยอะตอนนั้นก็เลย
โอ้โหไปร้านขายยาเนี่ยนะเาจะขายอยู่ที่
ร้านขายยาเนี่ยนะเราก็จะซื้อเป็นกล่องเลย
ค่ะ
นะแล้วก็ 100 ชิ้น 50 ชิ้น 50 ชิ้นนะใช่
นะแล้วก็ตอนหลังๆ 100 ชิ้นไม่มีะเพราะว่า
เดี๋ยวคนจะซื้อเยอะเาก็แบบแพ็ค 20  20
ชิ้น 50 ชิ้นนะเริ่มน้อยลงนะก็อันนี้นะ
เป็นสำนวนไทยเนที่เราจะใช้แบบกับเรื่อง
เกี่ยวกับโดยเฉพาะแบบธุรกิจแบบเนี้ยนะ
ช่วงที่ต้องรีบทำเร็วๆนะคะเราก็เลยใช้โอห
แบบนี้ต้องน้ำขึ้นต้องรีบตักแล้วูชิใชอ
หมดเวลาแล้วเหรอคะใช่ค่ะเราหมดเวลามาแล้ว
นะก็มาพบกันนที่ีทองเราหมดอืครั้งต่อไปนะ
คะค่ะก็นักเรียนก็ติดตามเราด้วยนะคะ
ขอบคุณค่ะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ